Hi. I want to check a couple quick
things and then
um and then I've had some
ideas on what I want to do.
uh I think I've decided that I want to
at least
try formatting this thing as a
Let
me ban that bot real
quick. I don't know why it is that only
Twitch has the
bots.
Okay, welcome folks.
So, what we're going to do right
now, we are going to
reformat a good chunk of this file uh as
a
class. I'm going to see if that cleans
anything up. And I
think it's kind of a tricky thing and
there's not really a fully right
answer, but
outside the mic is probably picking that
up. Fortunately, it'll be done soon.
Um, so yeah, the the thing that I've
realized is that
uh in a a dynamically typed language
actually classes start to make more
sense because you can't get the type
wrong on the call signature. It's kind
of silly, but there are these sort of
natural things built
into a dynamically typed language that
push you towards more classes over
strrus.
So, I'm just going to try to do it like
the Python way, but cleaner, like as
clean as I can, and see how that looks
versus this, which is kind of like me
doing something that would work really
well in C, but not great
This at least will get rid of this whole
mess here,
Some of these probably don't need to be
stored.
So here actually we don't want to set
policy up
front because it can get compiled.
I'm trying to be very disciplined here
so I don't break anything. And then the
plan is to go back several passes over
this uh and just cut it down as much as
possible.
If I get this file to a thousand lines
and everything still works as is and we
have like our like high quality RL PF, I
mean the best RL implementation in a
thousand lines is pretty darn
good. And this will do multi-achine too.
We haven't done much with multiachine
yet, but uh we do have support. There
are a couple people that use it. So,
this will be perfectly good distributed
as well. Welcome YouTube
folks. I've uh been away for about a
week. You can probably see in the
background with all the setup I've been
doing.
Why we have one
machine got to start somewhere, right?
You can kind of see it behind the box on
the rack
there. But there will be 40 machines
there reasonably soon. Hopefully soon as
the tariffs come down
policy stuff like global step and
epochs. Guess that goes at the start
We're going to get rid of last log time,
I'm sure. But for
now, put it
I
do that uh that's going to get be
removed. But so P3 was this like new
advantage function I
guess. I guess it was an advantage
function. Yeah. that I was experimenting
with. I still think that there's
something important in
there. I would like to come back to it
even before the next release. It's just
going to be a matter of how many hours I
can put in
streaming to get that all
done. Think this will go after our
setup. Or maybe here. Maybe we do put it
here.
Now, a lot of these things are just
setting params from the config to params
of the
class. That's a thing to
consider if I just want to like set all
of them automatically or something like
that.
this.
Uh, this does not seem to get used
anywhere else that I can
see. Epoch or
set, but step does not. So, we have
redundant ramps.
Hopefully the uh background noise is not
too bad here when I'm talking. I have it
noise gated and compressed as best I
can, but there's power washing outside
today. Lots of new uh setup for this
place.
A lot of these probably don't need to
even be assigned to the class in the
first place,
right? We can just do like config is
self.config and then it's just
config this instead of self do. Yeah, we
can simplify quite a bit here.
We do this after in a netit as
well. And ideally we would do this a
little later because uh first epoch
compile screws up screws us up a little
bit. Okay. So now print dashboard's
going to be a part of this
I don't like this being at the top of
the file like this. But
um we will see about
that just cuz like you open the file and
like you see this, right? Like what the
hell?
redundant. Fully set up. I don't know if
I'd say I'm fully set up. We have one
server in the background there. Uh
there's more equipment
coming. Stuff is still a mess and needs
to be cleaned. This camera quality is
actually going to improve. I have a
couple more cables and things
coming, but and I still don't have
running water in this building. Um, but
I'm like reasonably set
up. What? Oh, I think I don't think
that's a scar. I think I just dropped a
wrench on myself.
Uh, while I
was I was helping to put the where is
it? the big rack
together. But I did finally get to use
the equipment uh for the first time this
morning. And it's nice All my stuff
right here.
I have a couple questions regarding
puffer stuff. Yeah, of
course. I can answer things. Half the
reason I stream just here or you want me
to jump in the Discord?
Hello. Hello. Hey. How's it going? Yeah,
going good. Thanks. Thanks. Yeah.
Um, so I was basically trying not sure
if you've seen my messages in Discord,
but basically I've tried to uh been
working with the latest
dev.
Um, it's uh, but I've I've run into a
couple of issues and I wasn't sure if
this was the type of stuff that I could
uh, uh, that was just not working on my
own and or if I could like do any PR for
that or if it was a non bug or
something. Basically, I was trying to
run a default policy, so nonrecurrent
uh policy, and I've been using the I
think it was in a cleanl or model uh pi
file, and I've had a couple of issues
um with the latest uh Python file where
there was missing imports, some missing
torch import or something like that.
Let's see.
[Music]
Um, so let me link to you the exact file
thing. Oh, so okay. So,
um,
uh, let me hang on. I should just switch
branches, but I've also had B try to
help me and he said like it was working
with Python 3
3.12, but I've had issues running it
with it as well.
So, I wasn't sure. Maybe I should just
jump on the 2.0 O branch and just stay
there. Maybe it's just a little bit more
stable since I'm only running CPU.
So this is buffer snake with the RNN and
everything. This is now training at 2
point something millisecond.
I probably didn't test it without the
recurrent policy lately.
Okay. What's going on here?
I think there's some remaining E3D
stuff.
Mhm.
just some migration pains from uh you
know API changes. No worries. Let me fix
those.
Okay. Yeah. That's the point. No, no,
this is the point. Like I break stuff in
dev, right? But like I don't do like
really comprehensive testing or anything
like that on dev, but like you I it
should be very easy for you to just do
this and I'll just fix it live for you
really quick, right? Because like I
didn't test the non-recurrent policy.
Oops, I forgot. Right. Yeah, that makes
total sense. So, basically my question
is uh is it better if I wait for you to
be on stream and I I do it like this way
or or is it okay for me to just fix it
myself and and PR when it's like as easy
as this? For for instance, you can do
that as well either way. Yeah. I mean,
it's just like I've mostly been away for
the last week, which is not common,
right? Because I've been like I've been
helping put stuff together and getting
this stuff set up for the last week and
I just finally got um you know working
internet and was able to do stuff for a
couple hours last night and that's been
about the first time I've been able to
do anything here. But like this now just
returns this
because I know there's the same uh stuff
happening in a default policy um which
is well it's because there's a split
policy. It's the it's the default
without the recurrent. There's a
different code path for it. So the
recurrent is the one that we usually use
and that's the one that I test always.
Right? But you can see here it's just
like there's this this extra thing. And
now that I'm looking at this and this
ends up being the same code everywhere,
I'm like, okay, that's a little silly,
right? So like these things are always
in
flux. I value
um you know, constantly improving it
over having it always be stable API.
So are we looking to get a uniform uh
signature of what the forward method
returns? So action and value because
I mean this is all like I changed a
bunch of stuff right in this latest dev
branch and there are reasons for it.
Like for instance, this split forward
function allows us to have a much much
faster inference time
LSTM. You actually need to use two
different you need LSTM and LSTM. So
it's a little
jank and I don't like that I'm just
having to basically copy these uh these
functions either for now. But I don't
want a base class either. I don't want
there to be like a puffer model base
class either. We got to figure that out,
right? So there are a lot of these
things that are in flux.
What's going to be the difference
between the forward and forward train?
for train is called is the forward path
that is called uh when you are training
and when you use the LSTM
uh it will be
different because the there's like a
CUDA optimization that has to be done
New value is going to come
back bashed
It's just like there's some shape
differences, right?
Okay, there you go. So, that's 2.8
mil uh 2.9 mil whatever on snake.
Okay. And then if I do, let me make sure
it still works.
Yeah. Okay, there you go. And so what
what happens if you if you decide to use
uh the the standard policy that is in
the cleanl Python file because here you
have a specific uh policy for snake but
we used to have a bunch of policies in
cleanl file too. I'm not sure clean.
Okay. Yeah. I'm not sure if that's
supposed to still be in use cuz which in
where it was uh the cleaner
cleaner files. Yeah. This is this is now
garbage. Like this these are no longer
used.
Okay. These were these didn't do
anything either. These were always just
wrappers.
Yeah. Okay. So it's puffer lib models
their stuff in here. We have this
default
policy and then we have this LSTM
wrapper. And we have this comp policy
and we also have this reset.
Okay. So that's where I should look for
because I've tried to use the default
policy and say it wasn't working. I
think there's some uh remaining stuff
about E3. I mean I I've had some
remaining stuff about A3B. Not sure.
Okay. Hang on.
It seems to run. Okay. Well, this might
might mean something on my end, so I'll
check. I mean, I could have missed
something as well,
right? It's I'm not infallible. I go
fast and make mistakes as a result,
right?
Um, like you're allowed to criticize
stuff. Like I screw stuff up very often.
It's just that the overall pace of
progress is better as a result. Um, no,
it's okay. It's just Yeah, sometimes I'm
just uh confuses to whether something on
my end or just there shouldn't be E3B at
all is the thing.
I guess this is still in here, but we
don't use these
because you basically didn't find any
ways to make it 3D work and so you just
we're not using it for now. Okay,
I'm going to add I'm going to commit
these for you.
Okay, thanks.
Let me know if that doesn't work.
Yeah, just changes color, you know.
Mhm. Of course, I'm now then going to
have to do like a jank merge to this new
one. Oh, if I break it again, come yell
at
me. Oh, yeah. a cache. We're doing um
we're starting on a big refactor for the
release. The main thing.
Okay, so snake's working. Uh, can you
just uh show me the latest common you
used to train
carpole to make sure I'm trying that as
well with the with the default?
That's it, man.
Okay. Yeah, thanks. Perfect. Okay. Yeah.
bet added
um bet like went and implemented no
depth cart pull for us. It's really
nice. It's trans in like a couple
seconds. Even like really simple stuff
like that is actually quite helpful to
us. Just like having classic benchmarks,
And were you you're doing voids or you
on a different end?
What end were you doing? Uh I'm not the
one working on boys. I was working on
and everyone has different freaking
usernames like literally everywhere. My
bad. Yeah, maybe I'll maybe I'll merge
them into a single one. But no, I was
working on a common pool resource, but
Oh, yeah. Yeah, that's a cool length.
Yeah, I remember we merged that. That is
a very cool end. I would like to I've
been improving it.
I would like to see some policies doing
something on that. It's like it's kind
of a tricky problem cuz it's like a
delayed gratification kind of a thing.
Um like honestly you could probably come
up
with like you could probably show that
it's kind of tricky to do that even
without it being a multi- aent thing.
Like does it even does it even train
with one agent or do they just harvest
everything?
Uh that's a good question. That would
probably be insanity, right? And it
should be very easy to configure, right?
You just pass one agent per end the
config. Yeah,
I've actually spent quite a lot of time
trying to make them to work. But uh
yeah, they just end up harvesting
everything. Uh so far I saw a paper on
this, right? There was just a paper on
this on like um you know agents overh
harvesting the bushes or whatever. I I
don't know if it was deep mind or apples
or like whatever but yeah I saw I saw
something on that and now to be fair I
don't know if their solution was any
good. Very often like these multi-aging
problems people come up with like very
very hacky and brittle like very fancy
solutions.
Okay about that I had another question
related to multi- aent uh like how would
you handle dynamic number of agents in
in the current stuff because we're
flattening everything, right? But let's
say you have a uh I mean in NMO I'm sure
you have a um
in old dynamic number of in old versions
I did in the new version I didn't want
to deal with it. Um so to answer your
question in 2.0
And in some of the not too too recent
dev branches, it's kind of just works
because you set this mask and um
anything that is not like anything
that's masked out just doesn't get added
to the experience buffer. But in the
more recent stuff, uh we restructured
the experience buffer in a way that
makes that a little bit harder. So we're
kind of punting on that for now. Uh that
said, that is going to be something that
we're going to uh to look at like how we
adjust for. I don't think it's going to
be that bad. I think we're going to end
up like with a couple padding segments
or something in the data. Um because we
have GPU drive, right? And GPU drive uh
GPU drive actually
requires this type of stuff to
work. But you know, ideally in the
current form, GPU drive requires that.
in general like whenever possible I try
to restructure MS to not do that because
from an infrastructure perspective like
we can handle it but it's like so much
easier and cleaner to handle things
efficiently when you don't have that.
So whenever you have an M that's like
yeah I could just respawn the agents and
then at EVEL time it'll still work for
the most part right like they'll still
want to do the same thing even if agents
are like cut out it's
fine but it's it's not even an algorithm
problem at all. It's literally just
annoying infrastructure buffers.
Yeah, because even then in the current
way that you're uh dealing with it, it
means that you have to start with a max
number of agent uh and you're just
masking out the ones that aren't there
anymore. That's basically it, right? But
yeah, but like this is like this is not
even an RL problem. This is like a
computer's problem, right? You want to
have your your you want to have your
buffers pre-allocated to that if you
want stuff to be fast and like all the
frameworks that do this like dynamically
like oh yeah we just store stuff in a
list and then you train at a thousand
steps per second yay like no don't do
that.
So it's probably just going to be like
try to do it as little as possible
combined with relatively efficient
masking.
Okay. But like this has become a lot
less interesting of a problem to me
frankly because like I kind of realized
that that annoying like variable number
of agents thing. It was the
infrastructure difficulty associated
with that was masking a lot of like the
cool multi-agent problems that you'd
want to think about. So like you know
you were trying to think about cool
multi-agent problems and collaboration
and things and actually you didn't get
stuck on those at all. you just got
stuck on the infrastructure associated
with variable num agents. If you just do
it with fixed num agents, things get a
lot easier. You just have to like
rethink some MS a little tiny bit
cuz it's a little get stuck, right? It's
a little silly to get stuck on a uh like
a fundamental research problem because
you can't implement a buffer or
whatever.
Well, I mean, okay, well, you could
basically have like a fixed size buffer
and then not even you don't even have to
respond the agents basically and just
max mask them, right? Cuz I mean, you
might have environments where it's
important for you,
you can reuse uh the same row. Yeah.
Yeah. Right. Right. Right. I see. Okay.
Yeah. So, that's fine. That probably
fixes 99% of the It does the dynamic
number. Okay. Cool. Cool. Thanks. So, I
mean, you can get really pedantic about
it. I'm getting sprayed with power
washer. The window in front of me is
um let's hope that those don't break
with all my stuff
here.
Uh yeah, like you can get really
pedantic about it and try to handle
every single possible case or whatever.
And like I think petting zoo did this
like there's this knights archer zombies
m that has like heterogeneous spaces and
like variable numb agents like all the
things ever and like yeah look it works
we can handle it and yeah but you can
train at like zero steps a second or
whatever. So like there's not much point
there's really not much point in
handling everything if it's going to be
slow is kind of what I figured out.
Yeah, about that. Is the MI agent uh
from meta stuff binding supposed to work
or
the what agent?
Uh M agent or MA agents? Not sure how to
M agent is not meta. Those are totally
different.
Okay. I I thought I was from meta. Uh
but yes, I see there there are bindings
for meta. MTA is not from me. It's not
from Facebook. It's a just like a
different new like small uh research
group. Um Okay. And
it's it's kind of like this factoryesque
envir where like agents are collecting
resources and converting resources to
energy and like converting one thing to
another. Um and yes, it does work. Now,
we've recently had a little bit of a
difficulty reproducing the really good
training run that I set a couple weeks
ago. I suspect something just changed
under the hood in like one of the M uh
the M commits or something, but uh you
know, we'll be getting that back because
we did set soda on the on that
environment a couple weeks ago or a week
agoish before I left and it's very
unusual for me to like lose a run like
that as well because like I'm usually
pretty good about tracking that stuff.
So, uh I I don't know. I suspect
something changed.
I don't know what it would have been,
but it's probably something dumb. Like,
you know, there was a specific commit I
trained it on and then I probably like
pulled a new end version when I was like
messing around with Aaron on learning
progress and then like I don't know like
something got reintroduced at some
point. It's probably something done like
that.
Okay, I see.
Right. Yeah, basically I just wanted to
start doing some experiment about uh ex
different exploration strategies and
that's why I've been uh trying really to
be able to run most ms in perfect if you
want uh exploration stuff the active
area the active research that we have on
that is with Diane
um I I've seen it do things on snake I
have not seen it make snake learn better
stuff but you can definitely get it so
that you can visually tell apart which
which uh policy is which
snake. So I think that there is
something in it's not quite dian like
the original paper. I've done some
modifications to it but there's
something there about like training
visually rec uh distinct
policies that should allow you to
uh that should allow you to like get
better
exploration. That's what I would
suggest.
Okay. C can you uh say again who's the
the other dude working on this on what
on Diane? No, Dian's a paper name.
D. Yeah. Yeah. So D like Diane is the
the paper name. This is I was working on
that one. I don't have anyone else who
is working on Diane specifically. though
the meta guys are interested uh in
Diane. I can tell you that because like
they also would like exploration stuff
working. I know exploration is kind of a
tough one because there's been so much
bad research on like exploration in RL
because it's just a not a it's often not
a well- definfined problem, right? Oh,
we want ex agents that explore more.
Well, what does that mean? Right? It's a
tabularasa agent. Oh, well, they should
go through all the rooms. Well, how
should they know how to do that? Like by
what mechanism should they know how to
do that? It's a tabularasa agent. How
should they learn that? Like what is the
objective that they're maximizing? Oh,
exploration. What like it's circular,
right? So like people try to maximize
like surprisal which you can actually
quantify. Um you can quantify that in
terms of like value function changes or
you know error and error in predictions
or stuff like that. Um people try to do
like countsbased stuff which kind of
janky from what I've seen. It works only
when you have explicit counts otherwise
it doesn't. Um people have tried to do
noise based stuff which is like R&D
style work which is a little bit janky
as well. Uh the thing that's been the
most interesting to me I think is like
uh behavioral diversity with the Diane
line of stuff. And we have some
modifications that I think are pretty
close to doing something in there uh in
here. But like it's the type of thing
where I would probably have to go put
together a test M that's just like an
empty room with an agent or whatever and
just see like can you get different
agents to go in different directions or
something basic like even something that
simple is
not like you don't get that by default.
Yeah, I was thinking about basically you
would need uh probably to make better
progress you need a dedicated amp which
uh probably makes things easier to
develop. Uh like a very simple one
actually as you said doesn't need to be
complicated but even just an empty room
with some agents that start in the
middle would already be something. So I
mean you could try I if you want to
check this stuff out like go take a look
at the some of the Diane stuff that I
have. It's very short. It's in that
file. It's all Matt Clean Puffer file.
Um, you can ask me questions, whatever
if you get stuck.
Sure. That would be like a good research
side stuff. And if you're trying to get
involved with like research side
contribution, that's a good way to do it
as well.
Yeah.
Okay. All
Um, okay. Yeah, actually one last
question about um multi- Asian stuff.
So, right now we're just uh training all
the agents are contri contributing to
the same policy. Yeah. Um
uh unless I'm wrong. I think uh well all
the experience from every agents is just
being batched together and sent to one
policy and then all the agents Yeah.
Okay. So what would happen if you wanted
to model some very independent
behaviors? Let's say from a very naive
point of view, you would want every
agent to have their own policy.
How would you want that? So, because
I've done that before and I've done that
like literally in 2018 or whatever, it's
not fun. And the reason it's not fun is
because you're splitting your data n
ways now, right? You're splitting your
data across a whole bunch of different
policies. Um, there are a couple cases
where it makes hardware sense to do
that. If you look at some of like
Brennan's work on Madrona, when like the
agent batch sizes get to be so large,
you can't train anymore. So, like you
may as well just train extra policies to
play against. That's a thing. Um,
there's also work that's like indicating
that environment diversity is more
important than behavior diversity. So
like it might make more sense to look at
like automated end randomization more
than automated opponent randomization.
Um, that I would also kind of buy. I
think though if you like to your point,
Diane does tie in with this because what
Diane lets you do is it lets you get
conditionally different behavior out of
the same policy. So you actually still
get to share all that experience and use
it to train the one policy. you get way
more training data but still potentially
get different distinct behaviors. Now
getting that to actually work is very
tricky. But if you were to do that then
you would basically eliminate the need
for all forms of like historical or
fictitious selfplay uh league training
like you could kind of do it all within
one policy and share all the data and
that would be very very powerful. So
that's kind of why I like the Diane line
because it's not just exploration it
also kind of solves like multi- aent
competitive dynamics being jank at the
same time.
Okay. Okay. But but then what would
happen if you were to want to model some
sort of multi- aent setting let's say um
I don't know you want to model some uh
urban uh citizen path or something some
social dynamics where you actually do
want each agent to uh display a very
different sort of behaviors
uh maybe with uh some agents uh uh
sharing their own policy with their kids
if you were to like you know
specifically let's talk about you know
social dynamics some some some sort of
uh genetic stuff that gets passed away
to the child um in this case you would
truly want them to have a different
policy right well then that's not even
going to be RL necessarily anymore if
you're doing genetic stuff
um and also like you got to be careful
because if you're just training if
you're just going to train a bunch of
policies on the same data they're going
to learn roughly similar stuff anyway
ways subject to I mean I have a paper on
that sometimes they don't but usually
they learn pretty similar stuff so like
it's not the first thing I would look at
let's put it that way just training
independent policies it's like oh I want
independent behavior so I want
independent policies that's not the
first thing I would look to say that um
because first of all each agent is being
computed independently and has an
independent state anyways when you have
a shared policy right it's not like
you're it's not a joint it's very
different from like a joint policy in
which you're taking n observations from
n different agents in and then
outputting jointly n different
decisions. No, you're still outputting,
you know, each agent's decisions
independently and conditioned on their
own state.
So, I mean like there is reason to do
this stuff. Like if you look at league
play style stuff, um that's definitely a
thing. But like I almost wonder what
would happen with the League Play stuff
if you tried to just make it conditional
on the same policy. I actually think
that there was some follow-up that might
have done things like that. Um it's one
of the things I want to look into in the
next like pass on re next research pass.
All right. Yeah. Well, that uh that
crit. Thanks.
Mhm. Um, yeah. All right. I think I'm
going to go back try to uh, you know,
just uh make the latest step branch work
and then uh, Sounds good. Maybe I can. I
actually had a couple of improvements
over my M2, so maybe I can PR that once
I'm done, right? Yeah, looking forward
to I've just been on autopilot
refactoring stuff here.
Yeah, I've seen that. All right, good
chat. Uh, right. Yeah,
thanks. That's cool.
So for folks watching, if you contribute
to Puffer Lib and you have
questions, that's how easy it is to get
help when you get stuck.
to one message on. I do have one meeting
that is going to be scheduled
today. Often have meetings that are just
scheduled same day. I honestly think
that's better. You should not have such
a full calendar that you can't just like
schedule stuff same day.
I get way more stuff done when I have
like fully open calendar and like no
pressure on any specific Okay.
And then this roll out
thing is separate,
right? This roll out thing is
separate. So that's everything that
needs to be tabbed. Uh let's just see
what I forgot.
oops. All right. So, we have to fix the
call signatures.
puffel. But like now that I have these
two files together, I can kind of see
that they're like they're coupled kind
of weirdly, right?
like the amount of stuff that I'm like
grabbing from Puffarel here.
Thomas. Isn't that like
ridiculous that you can do that? You can
just leave a trailing comment and then
like the tpple evaluates to true.
And I actually don't hate Python as much
as like a lot of devs do, but when you
start writing too much
Python, there's definitely such thing as
writing too much Python.
So this is tabbed. Uh this is indented
one too
much.
Wait, this is
not Oh, this is not
invented. What happened?
Okay, these do not need to
be these don't need to be here, right?
These can be
untapped. They don't depend on literally
anything.
And there's your instantaneous
training. It
works.
So, setting up the
warehouse. Welcome.
We have uh pretty much everything except
except the servers. Well, there's more
equipment as well. So, but we have a lot
of stuff nicely set
up. It's just
like 40 capacity with uh for 40 machines
for training agents and 1,000 square
feet for gym equipment to train me.
though. Like the gym area, the gym and
server area is like twothirds of the
space.
Okay. So, what do we think about this
initial
refactor? There's way too much stuff
imported
here. Hang on. There's We can
consolidate this, can't we?
Yeah, you're looking
different. I should be looking about the
same except for the new camera, which
this is not the final camera quality.
This is
um All right, here we're going to do a
product unendorsement on stream. Don't
buy these cables. They suck. They put
too much force on your other important
things and this thing broke my nice cam
link within 30 minutes of using it. So I
am uh I had to buy another one of these
which probably will be here today or
tomorrow. And uh then I will actually
have full camera
quality. I also have to probably
fine-tune the audio a little bit. But we
do
setup. The goal is to upgrade quite a
bit.
It took a while to figure all that stuff
out.
Okay, that works nicely.
Now, what do we think of the new uh the
new structure
here? Lot of imports. I want to like
compress dependencies a little bit. But
then we have clean
puffl with what will be like better
grouped
arguments. This is now how long is this
249. So it's a little under 200 lines
for a net. I think we can easily get
that down to like 150.
This print dashboard is way too high
up. It should be eval
train. And then we can put this stuff at
the bottom.
Okay. And now the bottom of our trainer
is 900 lines.
So if we can cut two 300 off of
this, which we should be able to do, not
just today, because uh some of it
requires like removing code paths that
we no longer need to use for which we
need to run really comprehensive
experiments.
I do probably want to do like the
distributional RL thing though. I think
we should try that at
puffer. I guess we just start on
refactoring all this.
Um, is it
crazy how much other stuff from the
config do we set?
We don't set like a ton of other stuff
in the config, do
So, but we do end up accessing the
config a ton, right?
this? I knew what I was going to do.
What if I do this?
That probably
cleans a lot of stuff up,
right? Is there any reason that would be
a bad idea?
particularly. Is that reasonable to do
for something with a massive
config instead of keeping the config
around and having to like
do stuff from
that. I mean the alternative,
right? Okay, hang on. There are a couple
of alternatives here. Let's not be too
ridiculous. There is actually a value in
knowing what comes from the config
because you can know what you have to
set in the config. So what if instead of
doing
that, what if I do selfconfig equal
config? I remove these and then I
exclusively grab stuff from the
config. What about that?
are Well, if you had to like overwrite
the device or
something, then it wouldn't be so
good. Oh, you can also delete the self
from all these. You never want to be
doing selfconfig whatever. It's just do
the one
access. I uh I intentionally have my
self keyword in a really annoying to
read font so that I use it less
Okay, this now works
again. So, we no longer have self-config
everywhere. We no longer have mixed
config and um like config stuff with the
clean RL uh clean puffl stuff. So, that
shortens a little bit, right?
Okay. 1450 lines. A little tiny bit
shorter as
well. What's the next thing to tackle? I
think I want to look high level
first. Let's look for high level wins
first. You can really like fine-tune
this over time.
LSTM slice
shenanigans. There's stuff to
fix. I could get rid of cron
here. I still want to do stuff with it
though.
I'm just looking for like where the
majority
of of fluff
is. There's a little bit around
LSTMs. Like there's a little bit around
logging. There's a lot around uh
different advantage functions.
And a little bit of brown dying as
well. Experience buffer stuff
losses, little bit of flop. Like it's a
lot of just there being a little bit in
a bunch of places.
little bit in
storage. This is P30 and like
alternatives, different
methods, things that don't need to
necessarily be
supported. Too many options is
back. Saving and loading needs to be
changed as well.
the dashboard. The dashboard is long,
but the dashboard's actually pretty
dense with uh correct
good. Got some distributed shenanigans.
We've got this count params. It's used
once
log. Yeah, there's a little bit of fluff
in mean and
log artifact
stuff.
Okay, I'm pretty confident then we're at
the point here
where I mean this stuff. Yeah, like
there are few there are a few things
that like I just haven't bothered to get
to. Um profiling is pretty
dense. So yeah, there just there are a
few things I haven't bothered to get to.
Um, there are a few things that could be
done
better, but generally like this is
pretty good what we have here. It's just
that we have a lot of leftover fluff
from um all these other methods that
we've been like supporting and then we
have leftover fluff
um just like little bits here and there.
So probably most of the optimization is
going to come
from or a good chunk of the optimization
is going to come from little bits of
fluff. Just removing little bits of
fluff and then a little bit of the
optimization as well is going to come
from
uh us figuring out those new methods.
Let me just go look up one thing to see
how likely it
is. What was the
uh
distributional? What's like the main
one? Is it this one?
main the main one that people use,
right?
I'm just checking this because I want to
see how hard it would be to like mess
with P30 real
quick. If this does anything
Okay, so this is all their math that
they say you can skip. Lovely. We did
some
math. We will model the value
distribution using a discrete
distribution whose support is the set of
atoms. Okay, this is all this math and
literally they're just bucketing the
value
function. This is a softmax.
So all this math just to say bucket the
value function.
So hang on. This
is if I can just figure out what their
algorithm is. We can probably do this
very quickly.
Uh, let me see. What's this say? French
girls are interested in getting involved
with your RL drone
project. Have to find an object in a
room. Shoots a laser at the
object. Oh,
cool. Yeah. Yeah, I mean we haven't
really done much with the drone stuff
yet, but we do have some people in
Puffer that have built like a fast uh
continuous end. And Spencer's also been
interested in this stuff as
well. See if I can find
it. They're doing coordinate. So is the
stuff they're doing at the
moment.
Um, so multiple drones. Yeah. Is the
stuff she's doing at the moment like RL
or is it just coordination with drones
and like the RL is the next thing to
try? Cuz if there's no RL in it yet, we
do have there's some students here. If
you scroll up a bit, trying to see where
it is. Yeah, these guys um they made
like a really simple drone sim in Puffer
and then they trained it really fast and
they're looking to PR it as well. It's
right
here and they actually ran it on a real
drone and it did like kind of okay
apparently.
This thing doesn't run. But
space. Not RL right now. Well, then this
is a good spot to start because it's
like relatively simple
sim. Would be good to get this thing in
puffer. Would be good to get this thing
running on more real drones. And I have
lots of space here if I want to. Like I
can order some to here as well. We can
see uh how they do on real drones. I've
got lots of space where it doesn't
really matter what they run
into. I'm afraid to report RL works. RL
is
good. I've been trying to spend less
time on X.
Honestly, would never work on
RL.
No, RL is
good. It's just
hard. But it is good.
now? Oh, I don't even have this in here
at the moment, do
I? Cuz this was C. This wasn't CUDA,
right? Or did I write a CUDA kernel for
this? Oh, wait. I thought I did. Yeah, I
have P30 right
here.
Yeah. Well,
I'm trying to think how much I want to
like put into this right
now. I should probably do everything
except this
first. Yeah, that would be smarter. Like
it's my tendency to want to dive into
the rabbit holes here, but it would be
way smarter to just like go through do
the line by line optimizations, line by
line like cleanups, and then we'll see
how much code we end up left
with. Starting literally from top
here. Need this anymore.
Yo, stuff works on the latest dev
branch.
Thanks. It
should generally things should work by
default unless I break them.
Ideally, I'd be knowing puffer enough to
confidently fix stuff. No
worries. I try not to break too much
stuff.
Is there a reason this has so many of
these these
lines? Can I not
like Does it like have to be a certain
number of
boxes? For some reason, it's an eight
line box. Like exactly an eight line
box. I don't know why
The corners actually break on my rounded
box anyways, don't they?
Does every policy is supposed to output
actions? Default model outputs
logits. Every policy I think is supposed
to output logits not actions.
I think it's labeled actions, but it is
logits or something like that. I need to
clean some things
it? Did they add this
recently? I don't think IPRed it,
right? Well, that seems like it just
works, right?
I forget if it like looked worse
on ASI or
optimizer is not optional. So, I don't
know why there's a default
it? So, we don't
need we don't need this.
reasonable and takes either wand or
Neptune which you pass in
sweeps. Hang on, let me see. Why do you
Why do you pass this
in? Okay. So, you knit stuff in
here, right?
and you do a bunch of
nonsense and then when you call
um, yeah, the way I have this set up,
there's no reason to pass these in,
right?
something. But like all this stuff
should be probably just wound up into
the
uh into the
training. So hang on. You have your back
ends.
stuff. Yeah, I think Clean Puffer should
just eat this.
The only thing is that there's this args
of XD and args of tag.
expect.
Ah okay. So they
uh they have Neptune scale. Now,
Is there any reason this can't just go
into config?
stuff. Yeah, this
is Neptune and it run.
This doesn't even get
used. This ID
doesn't. Resume doesn't get freaking
used either.
I see. So that because I didn't
implement it yet. So there should be
this is for
resuming. We should be able to do
this. I just haven't done it yet. Fine.
Yeah, these can just be none by default.
Vault.
Yeah. So, it's args of run
ID. Okay. But stuff in base doesn't get
passed. Oops. Covering
chat. The stuff that's in base doesn't
get passed in. Only stuff that's in
train gets passed
in. Move it to train for now and then
figure it out.
maybe. Or maybe move everything under
workspace to
name. Okay. So, we'll just we'll leave
that one for now, but we'll do this.
We'll configure our
loggers
ideally late as
bad.
Okay, then we can actually take these
args out.
now. Args of Neptune. So this is now
going to get screwy again.
It is.
Do I want to thread all this into a
um Where is
it? Here's your
train. So, we want to thread all this
together.
I kind of want to like just get rid of
this whole function at some point, don't
um
into just the bottom like main
script. That'll work for everything but
like sweep and DDP.
Yeah. So, there's like two there two
different things going on here,
Could this logic be in sweep
somehow?
Could be in
sweeps. I don't know what you
expected. I I don't know what you
expected doing
that. I have four PRs
open. What? What do you have
open? Oh, very nice.
And these work.
locally. I can fix the slice error, but
doesn't train well
locally. Does it train
like that means it doesn't work,
right? because this definitely trained
well
bind. Okay. Well, this is fine if this
actually works. Let's see.
We have
binding you. It says doesn't train well
locally on triple triad. Like does that
mean something broke because it trained
well before or does this mean that it
doesn't train with like Adam and
whatever defaults are there for muon?
Yeah. So things don't work locally,
right? But did
test. Yeah, cuz the puffer box you were
on got sent to main
gear. I need to get more puffer
boxes.
Okay. Well, I'm gonna have to figure out
who's on what box and give you
one. Okay, you know what? Let's just do
Let's do something.
they're just yolo
merging your
stuff.
one. Why is
um why is there so much new stuff in
ending
[Music]
No, that is
sauce. Okay. But like I think you're
misunderstanding the
way this is supposed to
work. I hope I didn't just merge that in
the other
clean. I don't care if it doesn't break
anything. It's going to cause me
headaches if I don't now look at it and
figure out. Um, hang on.
already. And I did not make a binding
for
snake. Uh, was Connect 4 this fast
before? What did you do on speed with
Connect 4?
And I got to now look I got to look at
both these closely
here. Which is the run that I should
compare to?
None of these seem to
uh to do
one. Well, you didn't run any You don't
have any full runs
here, right?
weird. This is
like way faster than before.
Well, you don't have any numbers, right?
Like I guess I have to do my own run
There.
Width and height shouldn't make a
difference.
Okay. So, it's hardcoded. You still have
hardcoded depth
three. Oh, wait. That's on your locals,
probably.
Yeah, these are close.
Okay, these are quite
close. I don't know why the M is a
different speed. It could just be
machine
[Music]
differences. I don't actually even know
if there are speed differences. This one
looks fine. Let me uh let me do your
other N
here cuz this one is the one that's
sketch. I thought I I thought I told you
about this. Let me see
here. Is you should not have to be doing
stuff like this.
a hard-coded agent depth. I thought that
maybe you'd reduce the opponent like
search depth or something which would
make it way faster, but you
didn't. Okay. So, the issue with this,
I'm going to guess,
is you probably
did you probably use the wrong
API. Let's
see. Yeah. So, didn't I show you
this?
like you're passing a param to each end
of
here and because you've done this right
you're like dramatically
complicating you're dramatically
complicating the C
code because you have you're passing
these listen where I literally I made a
separate API for this that's like really
easy and doesn't have you don't have to
do any of this but
Look, I thought I showed you this as
well. If I didn't show you this, it's on
me for wasting time, but I I thought I
had So, like Neural MMO has the exact
same thing, right? These are all
lists. Look what we do.
We do
envit. We put all these in a
list. And then we call
works. That is in the Python file. Yes.
But this
vector, you give it these lists, right?
Or you give it this
list and now it gives you your CMS as a
single
reference. Well, if I didn't tell you,
that's on me for not showing you this. I
know I told a few other people. I could
have sworn that you were on one of the
streams, but this is supposed to be like
if you want to do variable param
stuff, this would be the easy way to do
it. Now, let's see. I mean, to be fair,
maybe your way is better. Let me
see. I don't know.
Um, it kind of just depends on the
complexity.
Yeah. So I just added a second path so I
could keep the C file really
simple. Okay. So this is 80 something
lines to this. You have unpack with
index.
Yeah, cuz you you also added all this
stuff into the
snake file.
Well, the thing is you shouldn't have to
do this mess anywhere,
right? Yeah. This is also in the triple
triad PR as well.
Yeah, you have all the snake stuff in
here, too.
Well, I mean, look, if there is a way
that we can add
like we can add a few lines into the end
binding and simplify the Python for
people so you don't have to write a
loop. I guess then that's worth
considering. But there's definitely too
much stuff going into
the binding C's. Now, this one's
fine. Uh, this one you actually don't
even have
unpacked. Wait, you don't
have you don't have any of that stuff in
here. Okay. So, if you make a clean
triple triad PR, I can definitely add
that, right?
The thing is most ms don't need the loop
logic. It's only if you have
custom it's only if you have like custom
stuff. And then
like now snake isn't done because this
is a mass bat.
Like this likely this likely creates for
me at least two hours of looking through
this if not three and like trying to
figure all this stuff
out because you can't have like this
cannot be what the binding has to look
like,
right? Because this is way worse to have
people try to write this stuff in C.
Yeah. So, I'm still open to like doing
something like this, but and I actually
do want to look at the piece of code
that you have here for the list loop.
Um, I would say what you should do is
you should save
this because I want to look at this with
you uh maybe in Discord at some point or
whatever and
uh because it's potentially, you know,
we can unify the API with it.
But I think for now you can very very
easily do the snake thing as just like
the uh the neural MMO style loop one and
that'll just work immediately and then
we can have both of these
PR. Yeah. So clean up the PRs. Do that
and then we will uh we'll get that stuff
merged. And then something like this is
obviously going to be like I can't just
yolo merge this like right like come on.
Like I can't give this oh yeah here it's
so easy to write a multi- aent M. Just
write all this, right? Like nobody knows
what this is.
Thank you for the connect 4 PR. That's
very nice. We're getting uh more of
these M into
bindings, new bindings.
Not a waste of time when they're with
new
The cool thing is a lot of it is
actually inbound now. Like we get
inbound people just like asking about
puffer stuff, which is what we want
because I want to be able to spend my
time building stuff.
I mean, even things like what I'm doing
now, this is just incredibly basic and
just slow work. But like, cleaning stuff
up like this is very, very important for
usability. It's honestly like if I don't
do this, nothing else really
Cool. That
works. I
am Let me take a few minutes. I'm going
to go use the
restroom. I don't know. Do a couple
things here. I'll be back in a couple
minutes. And uh we'll keep going. Just
need to kind of refresh a bit. And I
have gym equipment in the
background. That's always nice.
One of the things I really wanted to
have was just the ability to uh, you
know, go do a light set of
whatever in between working on stuff.
Right. I was on um config replacements
for Neptune and uh WB. All
right. Do you notice his audio quality
better than before, by the way, or worse
or about the same?
versus um previous
location about the same is not good
because this is a substantially better
microphone. So I will have to fine-tune
that little on the quiet
side.
Okay, let's
close. We'll try
that. We'll try that for a little
bit. It should be like very noticeably
better.
Like this is a pretty ridiculous setup.
I've got a tripod with the camera upside
down mounted on it over here. I've got a
pop filter in my face with a fullsize
boom arm and a mic here. And then
there's actually there's a plan to put a
TV over there so I can just turn the
setup and do like, you know, paper
review or like whatever presentation
style stuff I want as well.
into Wait, doesn't mean and log do this
for you already? Hang on.
Mean and log should do this for you
already.
Yeah, but I don't actually think you
need to do this.
redundant. We can just do
this. And now we no longer have any
dependence on Neptune after this
point. So we should be
run. And we are down uh 80 lines from
earlier today
extensions. All my PRs are negative.
many
lines. You can't take too much credit
when I put a lot of work into that
endbinding file to make it possible to
do that. But I do appreciate the
contributions. It's a pain in the ass to
refactor all those
ends. I spent like a good two days on
that end binding to make that
work. It's okay. I do the heavy lifting
around here.
Okay, so now we can think about how to
load this extension
better. How does PyTorch do their CPU
fallbacks?
Okay. So, they have something fancy, I
guess.
table. Oh, hang on. Wait. Is there
something for
this porch library imple?
Huh? I think this is just feeding me
garbage.
It's telling me how to write a CPU
kernel and add a fallback for
CPU. Okay, this is it right.
So this is just all stuff that Torch has
done on top
extension.load. Okay, I think this is
better.
You may wish to okay here. So you have a
Python
function. You have some Python bindings
to C++ and CUDA.
You are using
elucidated. Local snake newbind dev
local what?
How did you even do that to like combine
two?
Oh, okay. Wrap the function in a PyTorch
custom operator.
autograd is
this okay custom C++ and CUDA. This is
what we want.
We're building a single wheel that can
run across multiple CPython versions.
Okay.
defining custom op and adding backend
implementations. Okay, so you
If you also have a CUDA
implementation, you can register it as
in a separate torched library
To add torch compile support, we must
add a fake tensor
kernel. Fake tensor are tensors that
have metadata but no
data. You can just do this with Python.
Cool.
To use the custom operator, we must
first load the C++
library. We will replace the unstable
PIBind 11 with stable API calls.
points.
Oh, okay.
So, a little
tricky, but um at least there is a
tutorial on this.
Let's see. Uh, first of all, how how we
on this
setup.py and I don't think we have the
extension in here at all, do
we? No, we do not have the extension in
here at all. We have it just in in the
Python. So we have to
Uh, this is a little sketchy actually
now that I'm thinking about it because
it makes a hard dependency on torch,
doesn't it?
torch. Hang on. Can we do it just from
uh the Python? I think we
Load
name
sources. This is probably it right here.
Right.
Okay, so this is actually mostly build
time
stuff, but I might still be able to do
something with this.
So this is torch
tensor for some reason. And this
is at
In order to use this from Python PyTorch
front PyTorch's Python front end, we
need to register it using a torch
library
API. This will automatically bind the
operator to Python.
VS float
gamma and then this returns nothing.
This makes the
operator available
via porch ops
extension my ad.
Okay. Expected arrow but found end of
file.
Uh, I still don't know if this is going
to be available
from torch. We will
see from torch.
name?
Extension. Probably just puffer lib.
No
module. Yeah. So maybe you do need to
actually have the module be
built like
this. We could do this for now, right?
command
class
equals H. You actually have to pass this
command class thing in as well
apparently. Interesting.
CPP. So what is this? Upper lib and then
upper lib.cpp. Something like
this. Unknown compilation option. Remove
command class.
Uh when you call setup
here, you do
have man class,
right? So that's weird that that doesn't
do
see bufferlib cython? Okay, built
something.
end to end working example from the
tutorial
here. Okay, this looks decent, right?
here. So, something's weird that I can't
do that.
Like this should work, right? Build ex.
Oh, hang on. Maybe I didn't have build
extension. So, import C++ and build
extension. Gotcha.
Got unknown compilation
option. Please remove command
class. Okay, so something's weird
here. Oh, you know what? This is cuz
it's in Syoniz.
Shoot. Well, how the heck are we
supposed to do
Also, most of these don't even need Syon
anymore, so we're doing something
screwy.
heck?
Oh, you just messed this up. Hang
on. So, this
is Yeah, this is just indented poorly,
isn't it?
What's this
close? Yeah, this
closes.
Okay, so I
apparently got this indented totally
screwy.
by this
error compiling objects for an
extension. Well, you don't need all
these, right?
Okay, this is
good. Now we do this. This goes to next
on
sequence on
end
plus should be less right.
Each element must be an instance
extension.
This should give me multiple extensions.
No.
Maybe this needs to be a list. I don't
freaking
know. It's just like
undocumented dumb build systems.
must be an
instance extension or a
Nope.
Okay, take Syon out for a second.
Portra extension must be a extension
instance or a
element of ext modules option must be an
extension
instance or twole. It is isn't it?
works. And then this probably works as
well, right?
Maybe the Sython one's a little
ambitious. Let's get rid of that for
now.
invalid. You need extra args, I guess,
for
these. It's fine. Can we get the torch
extension? We can get the torch
extension. Now I see
pufferlib.cython. So it said that this
would be available at like torch ops or
whatever.
advantage and there's no torch ops
puffer
has Okay, so this actually has compute
pup advantage in it.
This does have compute puff advantage in
it. Now it doesn't show up where we
expect it to though.
extension. And then how do they import
this?
extension
CPO
not. Ah, because they registered it
here.
Hey YouTube folks. I'm currently trying
to figure out um how to properly
register a custom op with PyTorch so
that I can have a clean CUDA kernel with
C uh with
C++ CPU
fallback and it's just demonic like
they're doing all sorts of ridiculous
things. It's just like so many layers of
registering and rappering and stuff. I
don't know.
Okay. So you actually hear
torch.ops.extension C++. So this does
actually go
Yeah, there's no
torch.pufferlib,
right? And there's no porch torch puffer
x
I mean, this is like a ridiculous amount
of code for this is literally their
tutorial on how to add how to have a
multiply ad kernel and it's like several
hundred lines of code.
originally. Maybe this needs to be
puffer Xed.
Let me see there.
C++ torch
library to find the
C++
version dummy C
module. But this is what I was doing
with pi bind anyways.
It doesn't seem to be defining
uh the
X.
Okay. And this is Oh, you can just
import anything from here. Okay. So,
it's not actually defined. It's just the
shitty library. Like, you can just
import anything from here.
Okay. Been not liking Torch
lately. Not going to lie. I have not
been enjoying torch.
registered. I mean, I guess I could try
this.
Okay. Well, I mean, I'm not going to
complain if I don't need
PiBBind. Where's the name space
end bottom?
Oh, I'm dumb. This
library, how the heck does it not give
me like an
undefined? Wait, do I
CPP? How the hell does this not give me
a torch undefined? I don't
even It can't be loading this then,
right?
So, we should have the It should be in
here
still nothing. But I don't even know how
this is like does this even give me a
warning if I just
like or an
error. No, it's like completely freaking
Oh no, we do get an error.
Okay, so it is actually loading the
correct file.
Why does it not
then? It doesn't bind.
You have to import the underscore C I
guess or something.
I mean, this whole thing is just janky.
The way that they're
like, this whole thing is just janky.
Like this code is fine, but then I have
no idea how this hooks into their like
their crazy registries with these
macros. This
extension they're not actually
testing they're not actually testing
this import
right here. They're importing it
directly.
Okay, hang
on. This is
one torch ops
extension. So, it is supposed to be
registered.
Yeah, this is like crazy. So, this is
now they're calling it
here through the registered
version. Yeah. So, like the extension
just isn't getting bound.
That's so
weird. And that's like so weird what
they're thing.
It's got to be something with this
like underscore
C. But how the heck is this
input? library
named_c. I mean this thing has to get
built,
here. Like how are they importing a file
that hasn't been built yet?
Do you have to import the underscore C
for this to be
available? Okay, I didn't think of that.
bizarre. Let me see how they imported
it. I think they said the import order
matters or something.
So in their
test they import
Ah, okay. So, it's not in the dur, but
it's
there.
Okay. So, we actually get
it.
Cool. Crazy
packaging. But we get it. Oh,
man. Okay.
do? Hang
on. Hang on a second here. Now I get to
see how they do their fallback at the
least properly. Right. So this has no
CUDA in it. So this will always
work. And then they have
test dimple.
implementations wait my add
CPP will add
CU ah and
this this registers
uh the CUDA in here.
Okay. So, we can do
this. And then they both load
shared, but other than that, it's
fine. And then this doesn't need a
module, I
name space puffer
lib. We get rid of the pi
bind which is kind of
nice. And we take
this this imple
And this is like this doesn't need the
name definitions it
seems. So this
is cute.
And probably this needs different names,
but we'll
uh we'll do it this way for
now and we will
see. Now in their
setup, they also import.cu, don't
they? Library
named_c sources
conditionally they conditionally add the
CUDA. We're going to do it for both for
sources we do puffer lib
cu. Okay.
And let's then just
do let's just like put
this into a
file. Can you ask a question? Yeah,
sure.
[Music]
Uh, can't initialize NVML. Okay, that
seems
like my drivers die. Yeah, my drivers
just died. So, that's fine. We can fix
that. That's
enough. Which is why you want the coup
to fall back as well.
trace?
Uh huh.
Yeah, it just doesn't give us a
freaking That's ridiculous. Where's our
error message?
runtime
weird? Is this a dot? This is a CU.
Yeah. Explicitly
include the runtime like that in a CU.
What's the point of having it that? H
Bizarre.
like not these
includes currently first year of
college.
Did I you learn data structures and
algorithms webdev or something? I've
only learned some C and
Python. So the thing is that normally
data structures and algorithms are
taught as part of your first or second
CS course in general because you really
don't know anything unless you know
basic data structures and algorithms. uh
you're very very rarely going to like go
reach for a try or very very rarely
going to have to I mean ex except in
specific applications reach for dynamic
programming but like you should know
what a you should know what a map or
addict is and how it's implemented you
should know what binary search is and
what is like what how it is implemented
you should know basic sorting like
there's a lot of things that you should
know that do come up quite often uh
computational complexity all of that so
if you haven't taken one of those, I'm
surprised because it's like it should be
among your first
courses. Um, it's also, and I hate that
this is the case, but it is pretty much
all of interview questions ever for
actual jobs are just like based on your
data structures and algorithms course,
which is ridiculous because it's like
it's one small piece and like you use a
small portion of it dayto-day, but
that's how it is at the moment.
Um, you should probably do that.
Uh, yeah, if you just like if you take
like this is what a language is and this
is how to do webdev, you do not know how
to program. Um, so you should definitely
learn basic data structures and
algorithms. You should definitely build
some stuff and then if you want to do
web dev from there, go for
it. Because the thing with webdev is
it's like it's just a giant mess where
like people have just like piled crap
onto the web development ecosystem for
the last couple of decades and it's just
like it's a gigantic
disaster. So
like honestly not much is going to make
sense unless you've just been
programming for a long time in that
space. Uh and then you can see like okay
this is the way they did this. That's
annoying but I get it right.
like junior webdev is not going to be a
fun job.
I can tell you
that. Especially with all the AI crap
now. It's just like people already
didn't understand what they're doing and
now they absolutely have no idea what
they're
thing. Yeah, we don't we don't cover
autogen stuff.
But let's let's talk about how pathetic
that is, right? So like we took this
very very simple thing, build a basic
web page. We piled like React and Next
and Tailwind and like all these like
crap modern things on top of it that
make no bloody sense um just to do basic
things. And now nobody knows how the
hell anything works anymore. So we built
an AI to figure out all of our
[ __ ] Like, isn't that just
incredibly stupid?
I I also think that the thing people
should realize is that there isn't there
isn't n't going to be like, uh, oh, I
don't know how to program, but I'm good
at using AI. Like, that just means you
have no idea what's going on. And you're
like, you might be able to hack out a
couple things over the next few
years, but like that's just zero useful
skills. Like, there are no useful skills
there at all.
I wish this would give me a freaking
build error.
Okay. Like if you want to do if you want
to use AI for
something, this is what I will do. We'll
see if this gives me anything.
Okay, it's probably they're outputting
the same stuff.
Then try something.
Oh, and there we go. We actually get
a This looks like a proper error
message. It was a name duplication
issue. There we go.
float is not a supported argument type.
Use type double
You tried to register a
kernel. Please use double
example? What are you doing? I can't
understand anything. Well, I mean, the
stuff I'm doing, you're not going to
know if you're just like a firstear
programmer. I work on high performance
reinforcement learning dev. Um, you can
see some cool demos at puffer.ai AI and
I am currently attempting to register a
CUDA extension to PyTorch with a CPU
fallback. So essentially I have a custom
piece of code that I want to hook into
uh the major the main learning library
that everyone uses and I want that piece
of code to run on the GPU or on the CPU
depending on the context in which you're
running it automatically without you
having to do anything. And that involves
digging through a bunch of sludge, which
is what I'm doing
now. So, what am I doing now? Digging
through
Okay. So, they have
double in this signature. I guess it's
probably I appreciate the
explanations. I mean, this stuff is like
kind of out there. This is not stuff
that most people will see for quite a
while, if ever.
So, and the thing is, it's like it's a
lot harder than it needs to be, right?
like when I was just writing my basic
CUDA extensions, if you just use CUDA,
it's kind of fine. Um, now when you get
the torch binding system involved and
stuff, then yeah, stuff is painful. Like
if I were just writing CUDA, could kind
of jam that. Let's kind of just see
Like how Python by default just uses
doubles cuz like screw it, we're slow
dynamic
module does not define module
export. Okay, so I I know how we do this
though.
Wait. Uh, before I spend more time, can
you try running triple
triad? Just local
compile. It doesn't seem to work
enough. I haven't touched this in a
while.
Huh? It just didn't release all the
memory. That's bizaro.
on.
Huh? Well, that's probably left over.
Broken pipe is
weird. There is something screw with
it. There is definitely something screw
with
it. Does it not have seating or
something?
off. Yeah. So, this I mean this is
missing like this has a no op or
whatever. We got rid of no
op. I got to finish this while I'm still
in the mindset to debug obtuse cuda
though. There. It does look like
something is
row. I'm about to pain just seeing your
work.
You get used to
it. Eventually like the feeling of like
feeling very dumb goes away and it's
like oh actually the code I'm reading is
in fact the thing that is very dumb.
It's like why is it like this? Why why
couldn't we have just built
simple simple CUDA extension interface?
Why did we have to do
this? Why do we have magic magic static
load macros?
still
nothing. See how they do their imports.
So they do add the CUDA sources
star.cu. Okay. So they have multiple
sources that go into this one
extension. All
right. Don't need this.
Do I need CUDA
extension? I need CUDA extension, don't
extension. It's already 12:17. Going to
sleep. Can you tell me what time you
start your live stream? Uh, it is
currently 2:49 EST. I generally try to
do a short stream in the morning
somewhere between 8:30 and 9:30 a.m.
EST. And then uh after breakfast like
say 10:30ish then I'm on for the rest of
the day. Modulo meetings and other stuff
I have to
do and I will be back streaming quite a
bit for the next several weeks.
Some of it
is in the trenches like random packaging
and extension stuff like this. Some of
it is cool research. Some of it's like
building new environments. Some of it is
working with
collaborators. Whole bunch of different
stuff. We do a lot of different things
around here.
Multiple rules
generate this build for lib.0
Oh
extensions
multiple there is multiple rules
generate this
by
sources. See, this is one extension
though, isn't
CPP. Oh, did they put them in uh
separate directories just for this
reason? That would be kind of evil,
wouldn't
it? I just thought of something.
and then shared is not going to be
there. Yep.
here. Puff advantage
[Music]
colonel. Puff
advantage. Did you mean puff advantage
row?
Puff advantage colonel. I probably did
the same
CUDA? Could it just not have block
comments?
Okay. So, what do we have here? Multiple
definitions of vrace
check. I know. I like I can fix all
these is the thing.
Uh, this is only defined once as far as
I can
see. Is it because both of these are
including
shared? That could be
it. It's probably including both of
these.
this max horizon undefined. Yeah. So
this needs shared
And this also needs a shared because up
advantage row is in shared C++.
declarations. Yeah. So, it's getting
included multiple times.
these are the two functions we need,
right? Max Horizon
I probably need the same code right in
uh the shared or in purple
not declared in scope. Puff advantage
row.
Okay, there we
go.
Now, now we have something
use float instead of
double in an operator schema
string. Okay, so this one needs to be
float.
there. Lovely.
So now we actually have
uh our CPU, GPU, fallback,
whatever. We have it all
running. Now the only question is going
to be how we how we integrate
everything how we do everything uh
cleanly here.
I don't really know if I feel like
messing with that at the moment to be
honest. Kind of want to just get the the
full thing running cuz like at least
this is the way like this will make it
clean in the place it's imported.
chunks. So, this like needs extra args,
I think.
F permissive. Yeah. So this this needs
extra
or maybe I do actually want to mess with
this here.
And actually you don't because
this Yeah, you just want to set the
pointer. Okay.
guess. But I don't have pedantic on
either.
We can siphonize
it like we were doing
before and just say that I've done
enough bloody
um packaging for one
day. That's an option.
Error handling is a
pain. Yeah, I'm definitely sick of doing
um I'm definitely sick of uh packaging
for one
Do
this. We do this. No
errors. Do this.
No
errors.
go. Uh, okay.
So it looks
Why is this like why is this a parram of
setup and not of the extension as
Did they not have this? I guess they
don't have this cuz they don't have
multiple
Does it still work if I do it without
this? Hey Quinn,
welcome. The camera is not a webcam and
it's going to look better than this as
soon as I get another cable for it.
I've
got well what should be a professional
quality AB setup now but um got to fix a
few small
things. I think that this still works
hopefully.
I'm seeing this getting
built. So, we'll
see. I mean, it's
like whatever at this point
lib. You have to import torch and then
you have to import
Do
this. Do it this
huh? I mean,
I How do we do this?
No. It's like adding stupid args, isn't
it?
Yeah, this is like
ridiculous. There just so many bad
decisions in here.
once cuz I just like I can't even I
don't know where the [ __ ] API would
be for this thing is ridiculous.
These are just like horribly
documented this utils nonsense.
You literally have to write a custom
one, don't you?
buildex. Let's see if this runs out of
the
box and we will go back because this
solution sucks.
sub
[Music]
tools. Okay.
and like the number of just ridiculous
build things
Okay. So, it does build the CUDA
extension right there.
I think you just have to be very careful
with this import, right?
Uh, okay. I don't know why it prints all
this
omitted only available through these
back
is there a place where we tell it what
backend is registered to
m and then this is registered right here
to CPU.
So, I see it right here. Will we be
streaming tomorrow? Should be streaming
all
day. Hopefully, I get past this by then
so I'm not just stuck doing this
nonsense because it's explicitly
registered here, right?
Still. Okay. So, here it like it
correctly finds the op. It's not just
inventing one, right?
Thanks. Yeah, I'm going to try to finish
this.
We definitely need to do
this, but uh that's not the issue just
yet.
Do we have puffer lib in here? Python
dispatcher
[Music]
registered cannot
run because the operator doesn't exist
for this back end or is omitted.
So, it is getting the right back end,
but then it's not finding. It's
dispatching to the correct back end, but
it's not finding
it. And I don't see I should see puffer
li in here, shouldn't Okay.
on. This has
it with the underscore C, right?
end? But no, it's definitely getting
it's definitely getting cold and built
like we're see we're seeing it here.
this. They import it in the
test. So they import
torch. They import their thing which
imports the C.
Yeah, you don't have to import it. As
soon as you import the underscore the C,
it should be working.
I don't know how it thinks it's
available from all of these backends
that I didn't
define. You can't click this,
right? Open source library that links
you to the Facebook page.
well. Yeah. So, it's available for these
backends and it lists a whole bunch of
I'm trying to think what I could
possibly be screwing
up. Maybe it is just something with the
setup. Hang
on. So, we
do double check their CUDA extension.
They have a
setup at their
This is not actually changing the
extension.
I have
this. I wonder if it's actually the
It's not smart enough to catch that, is
it?
know. I don't like that it immediately
copies these either.
Hang on. That's not good,
right? It immediately copies
stuff. I don't see puffer lilib. Um
um puffer's not getting built at all in
this
one. It's not there.
extensions.c
Python. That's not it.
Okay. So, that's weird,
right? It says it's building
it. Um, but it doesn't actually build
it. So, it is an issue with this
shenanigans.
This whole
Can I put a break point in here?
Probably not,
right? Oh, I
The issue is I don't understand what
this gets called
I just want to see if I can get it to
load with this.
two. Okay. So, we can definitely see for
sure it's not getting built.
or
dumped. Inspecting
indent
flies. I get some fly paper.
I was just had the doors open too much
with all the uh setup around here.
Ident. Did I mess something obvious up
in
here? Values. Let me see if I got the
syntax right.
Okay.
So, here is the mutated operators thing.
Wait, we must
specify that mutates the out
Oh, it's literally like just give it
some
random Okay, so I misunderstood how this
works. That's
even was probably not smart enough to
know. We'll
see. We're going to try this.
There's a mutate
thing is it was the other order,
right? Tensor of
Okay, so it still doesn't recognize this
thing even though it's definitely
building it now. Building it with the
correct back end as well.
I just like clone this repo real
quick and
see. Wait, why does it have vector in
here? There's no way this matters,
right? They actually use this
this and I
have
this. And you got your
imple
advantage. So I've kind of gotten
everything I think out of
here. Gotten pretty much out of
everything out of here.
Why did it even like define it? I guess
cuz I defined the extension. But yeah.
Okay. Well, that's actually on me.
That's actually my screw
Boom.
Okay, there is the
running
thing. Still a ton of work to do with
the
So there is one very nice upside to
doing all this. Um we also kill the pi
bind
dependency. So we have no pi bind now in
puffer lib since it's just a
capi. Uh so once I clean the cuda code
up it'll actually be probably a lot
nicer
now. But that was a pain. That was a
total pain. Okay.
Um, I got another hour and a halfish,
hour
45. I'm going to take a couple minutes,
use the restroom, wake up a little, and
then I think we're just going to like,
we've done enough packaging today. I'm
going to keep going on clean puffer.
We're going to keep finding more things
to clean up.
Um, yeah, we're going to find more
things to clean up. That gets rid of the
weird CUDA loading in here though at the
least. Most of the things that we have
to fix should not be that hard. Not
anywhere near that. So, I'll be back in
a few
Well,
um, we're like 60
lines into this file for optimization.
[Music]
Uh, that last one took a whole bunch of
hours.
There's probably a lot of stuff we could
do in here.
What?
Wait, is this a
thing? There's no way this is a thing,
right?
stable. Same. Okay. Well, there's some
stuff to mess with in the uh
flags, would
think. We'll see if there are any other
magic
flags. Where's KudnN.benchmark?
Benchmark.
Not really seeing any
improvement. Interestingly enough,
We'll look for more optins at some
point. For now, let's go back to this.
So, next thing on this list here is
um let's reset seed
here. Let's do this.
sensor float
32 medium.
Okay, so there might actually be
something here.
So, we'll do a couple quick things on
this and then we'll look at the
losses. That's why we weren't seeing a
performance difference with that other
flag.
Got an
[Music]
invite. Okay. So, this is slower here,
right? Whatever this default is is
slower.
40. So there is a difference, but it's
really not a huge difference.
Interesting. Oh, this could be why am
working though, cuz I had this
set. It's worth checking.
Okay, let's go to the losses thing
next. So, I wanted to see if there's a
better way of doing
this. So, I have it like this so that I
can iterate over them, I
guess. Here and here.
They don't need to
be uh accumulated really do
Well, it's not really any worse that
they are they are here though, is it?
It's cuz the print Well, actually, no,
they do need to be here. So, they show
up on the dashboard initially. I
I don't know how well Python handles
string keys internally and
dicks. I don't actually know if it's
slow or
not. You would hope it would do
something for static string keys,
but I mean, you never know.
Okay. So,
uh we can
potentially inline some more stuff here.
this config this config that is
like million times config here.
length. I think for now we can just
alias a few things.
stuff. Really, this stuff shouldn't
matter too much, but uh we'll leave it
like that.
experience
rows on policy rows and off policy
rows. We will punt for now because we
have not
seen any case where off policy rows have
helped but we do want to go there next
potentially.
I think tra length is
good or segment length
So this should now be
segments and then this is
device. I think this is going to go
print. This is going to go like
somewhere here.
The stuff I'm doing at the moment is
like very very basic, but I honestly I
think that this makes a huge difference.
And like often times the difference
between a good library and a bad library
is just like how often have you actually
gone through it and like does this make
sense? Is this as good as it could be?
Is this simple? Can I make it easier?
Can I make it shorter?
just
chill. Okay, it gives you your segment
parameters.
I'm pretty much just like trying to make
stuff shorter where possible, make names
better where possible, and like better
semantically group stuff where
possible. That's all I'm doing.
But like imagine I do this to the whole
file. I cut a couple hundred lines out.
I make a lot of lines shorter. I make a
lot of stuff make more sense. That's
like a substantially better library
right there. Right. Just by doing this.
An idea I really like is um white box
software. The idea that instead of me
trying to
focus really heavily on like giving you
an API boundary where it's like you know
you just read the docs, you just read
the API whatever I focus on giving you
like a really really concise simple easy
to read easy to modify code. So that
instead of having like a 20,000line
library that does most of what you want
most of the time, but you're screwed
whenever you need to do something that's
like outside of the design spec. I give
you one or 2,000 lines uh that does all
of that, but is also like way way easier
to modify.
The trade-off is you're not going to
have all the options, you know, upfront
of the 20,000 line API, but when you go
outside of one of those options as it's
intended, it's a lot easier to hack on
this and a lot easier to understand
exact
exactly what is going on.
line's too long, right? Where am I
cutting
these? Is like around
hereish. And I should probably cut at
least around like try to keep most of it
around here.
that. Yeah. I doubt people have like you
have this much screen space, right? I'll
check it on my laptop as well.
Why Abuntu over any other
OS? Well, I've used Arch for like 5
years. It's great until it explodes. Uh
I ran Debian on a bunch of servers,
which is fine until you realize that
Debian doesn't have any of the drivers
that you need. So, your stable OS needs
to use all the experimental packages
anyways. Um I've used both Mac and
Windows, which are just trolling for
development straight up.
Uh, what else have I
used? I think that's most of it. So, you
know, I probably missed a few in there,
but I've kind of covered most of the
bases with that.
Okay, so this is already looking much
cleaner. And then assuming that this
either gets kept or removed, one of the
two.
And I I like one of these things need to
be assigned. I always don't know like do
you do
this do this or is this
disgusting, right? Like I can never make
up my
mind. I think that's kind of gross,
right?
logically. I've also never been able to
make up my mind on stuff like
this. Like that looks too cramped to me.
But then like you almost want to have a
double space between sections which is
too
I think we just get to
do to do this now, right? We just get to
keep this
one like a bunch of
slices and then it's like a
multibuffered
thing. And slices are not hashable
though.
Can you not do this on a
device? You
We've gotten quite the upgrade in our
setup here, and I should be back for the
next several weeks with nothing to do
but
So they do make torch zeros work like
this now. I swear that used to not work,
right?
assert total agents greater than
zero. Probably do that anyways.
um, I have capacity now for 40
servers. You can just see it over the
box
thereish. Is that still on the camera?
Yeah, you can. It's just poking up over
the box. I have one
server. I need to buy 39 more as soon as
the tariffs go
down, but the tariffs are like plus 40%
right now. So, I'm waiting for that. And
then uh other than
that, bunch of gym equipment going in
there. Gym equipment. It turns out
commercial gym equipment is much cheaper
than servers. So, uh may as well treat
myself a little
there. especially if you get like
secondhand commercial stuff.
So yeah, buffer training facility.
Training for agents. Training for Okay.
I think this is going to get shorter
when I fix the slicing stuff. So, I will
uh I'll just leave it like long for
now. Mini batch size.
Guys, I guess you have to do
this. So, this is going to be for
gradient accumulation, right?
I guess if you do
this, not as bad, but like then you want
like this. So much space.
and then
dashboard. I like losses
here. It's down
[Music]
here. All right. So, we are
now That's a lot
cleaner. It's a lot a lot cleaner. Still
not finished yet. Even just the init
still not finished yet.
I've got uh roughly 40 minutes here
until dinner.
I guess they're like it annoys me that
there's still like all these little
sections that don't cleanly go with one
thing or another.
So all these self variables can go
wherever
end? We could also do something like
this.
I think they're only needed by this
dashboard
here. And so now you get to
see this gets set. This gets set.
I mean this should go in Vean honestly,
right?
Yeah, there's no reason to have this
here.
device. I mean this whole thing is a
block right? This whole thing is the
experience setup.
I mean the other option is like we do
this All
So, the experience section is long, but
it's going to get way shorter.
We might even just make this thing not
configurable because Muan's just better.
logging profiling initialization
dashboard. Okay, this is like this is
reasonable. This is like a good start,
I'd
say. Let's see if we can get this to
actually run.
a lot of
code, but I think if a good chunk of
this goes away from features we don't
really care to
support, it'll be reasonable when people
open Huh?
I would like a better way to check this
than doing an is
instance every time. I'm just trying to
like do some things for now.
Do you use end by anywhere in
here? Actually, I think you
We should put this in vectorzation if
we're going to do it this way.
handled as
tensor. Your non-blocking transfers
Okay.
Shorter. Still
runs. Still runs
Okay, so now we get to the logging
stuff.
Get rid of this for
now. We'll add it back better when we
need
I'm a somewhat confused here
because we've appended every single
item in a dictionary.
I mean, this is just poip trying really
hard to log whatever your crazy data
This
um, you shouldn't be able to have any
dictionaries left in here
essentially, unless you did some
weird weird weird stuff.
I like that this handles next to
dictionary infos. That's a common use
case even though I no longer use it for
native ms.
Is there any reason I can't just
um do the aggregation right
here? I can,
right? Because this is now I can just do
this, right?
here. Yeah, you don't use it at
all. Perfect.
Bomb. Oh, because you reset these
every Okay, we'll leave that as is for
now.
basically every little thing in here
that possibly be weird or confusing I
want out.
Oops.
Yeah. Okay. Be right
there. Thank
you. Uh, okay. That's it for today. Lost
track of time, guys. I am uh I will be
back either right after dinner for a
shorter stream or if not, then tomorrow.
So, thanks for tuning in.
Um, if you are interested in getting
involved with the
project, join the Discord here,
discord.gg/puffer. If you want to help
us out for free, start the repo. And
other than that, you can follow me on X
for more RL content. Thanks and I will
be back